[Music]  this hello everybody here for the in the  road may talk what do you drive  I got the jet bike I ready to see you  mr. GRU oh good great yeah  [Music]  they staying with violence  my name is I feel like I'm talking too  loud even though our proximity doesn't  require this time  you'll seriously think a puny little  child can be a village yes I am pretty  despicable you don't want to cross me  when you've done something evil to  impress me  [Music]  I'll take the stone back to the lair  I'll distract them  this is the biggest day of my life this  can just go something broke there was  villains in the world  [Music]  are you pulling on my leg  [Music]  did you just trade my future for a bad  Rock  oh I didn't mean to scare you now where  is GRU  you